[Musique]
le collectif les amazones d'afrique
véhiculent des messages contre les
violences faites aux femmes nous
défendons les femmes contre les
violences sexuelles physiques
intellectuelles voilà dans le monde à
travers la chanson à travers le
spectacle voilà les gens doivent venir
nous voir parce que nous avons des
message à véhiculer et à travers de la
bonne musique la musique des amazones
électro voilà feng dub mixé à la musique
africaine aux rousses africaine voilà
venez voir les amazones d'afrique ce
sera la fête et ce sera le show
[Musique]
on sachant que la violence il existe
aussi à la réunion donc on est très très
à coeur là dedans on est tous
sensibilisés et on sera que des femmes
on sera 18 femmes à les accompagner et
puis voilà j'espère que convenu on vient
tous de madagascar donc c'est des femmes
malgaches qui sont à la réunion qui
habite à la réunion qui vont être avec
les amazones et qui vont chanter
ensemble et on est vraiment très heureux
de pouvoir participer à ce festival
[Musique]
bien sûr ah oui c'est exceptionnel c'est
un événement unique et surtout dans le
monde du jazz c'est la première fois
qu'on va participer mais je pense que ça
doit être quand même impressionnant
j'espère que les gens vont venir nous
entendre ce sera la première fois pour
nous il faut venir voir les amazones
d'afrique et à la fin avec la chorale de
l'île de la réunion
ce sera du show que des femmes sur scène
mais nous serons accompagnés par des
hommes parce que les amazones nommé non
pas une guerre contre les hommes
mais le mais non une un combat avec les
hommes pour un monde meilleur pour les
pour tout le monde pour les femmes pour
les enfants et pour toute l'année
[Musique]
fini